uh your office is all the way down at  the end you have your own attached  bathroom by the way  oh um here's one of our best researchers  dick hey  uh hello there  what's up dude  glad to see there's another brother in  this stunning place  so um this is um gonna be your assistant  genevieve genevieve um what is this it's  the shining man all black people have  the shine you never shine with another  black person before no i grew up in a  white neighborhood and then went to  dartmouth i've met other black people  before but not like this  you got to get shined at by another  black person first and then you get it  it's kind of like facebook  what up dudes